dylan what's up man how we doing what's
up guys we got a lot of stuff to get
through and i got some fun questions for
you at the end that you don't know about
yet but uh today bitcoin on chain
derivatives and macro great title to all
these slides let's start with bitcoin
realized market capitalization the
realized cap what the hell is this and
why is it important
yeah so uh this is kind of a mainstay in
a lot of my slides my slide decks with
you guys and this is just kind of a
bigger kind of broad picture of the
bitcoin market so i realized cap is just
a the aggregate basically figure of
every bitcoin that's ever moved and the
price it was last moved so you can
almost think of it as like an organic
price of of bitcoin uh and oftentimes
during both cycles when the bitcoin
price goes parabolic uh realized cap
will will increase
with it but with a lag basically because
new capital is flowing in to the asset
and old coins are distributing um and so
basically
over the last about since summer since
about august we've seen these capital
inflows have have really started to slow
but in absolute terms they're still
pretty big i mean it's about 90 billion
dollars of capital inflow since august
um and to put that into perspective the
next slide there if you're looking at
the the chart in linear terms that
realize cap figure it's it's basically
since since august we've seen realized
cap grow by its entire figure uh at the
top of the 2017 market that should be
labeled uh 2018 january 2018. and it's
90 billion dollars so in relative terms
we haven't seen really the capital
inflows
for bitcoin to be a multi-trillion
dollar asset yet but uh in in absolute
terms uh the capital inflows are here uh
and they're continuing to come in it's
just uh for the time being
uh it's slowed up a little bit a little
lackluster in relative terms
okay when you think of this realized
market capitalization can you explain uh
is this a uh kind of backwards looking
metric to in your opinion or is it a
forward-looking metric in terms of do
you use this to understand what's
already happened or do you use this to
try to anticipate something that's going
to happen in the future whether it's
price or other types of metrics
yeah that's a great question i think
with realized cap it's it's more of a
backwards looking metric obviously
because you can see just you know the
price of it by which every coin has ever
moved realize price is just that
realized cap divided by circulating
supply uh where you can kind of be more
forward looking with the metric is if
say you take a ratio of um and i didn't
include it in this slide deck but that
market value to realize value metric i
present a lot it's just a ratio of price
uh to to this realized price metric and
oftentimes the lower it goes currently
it's about 1.75 um
real the mvrv ratio below one is like a
generational buying opportunity so uh
it's not option that we see it but
that's more of a forward-looking metric
and was when you take a realized uh a
ratio of these two metrics and so um you
know on a relative basis it's a lot more
attractive to buy bitcoin at 40k today
than it was uh at the beginning of last
year um so that's more of a
forward-looking way of looking at this
metric
got it now we've got the realized price
30-day change which is basically just
taking what is it the 30-day kind of
rolling average and looking at how
that's changed over time
yeah so this is just a rate of change uh
almost a derivative not to be confused
with derivative financial markets but uh
for any calculus nerds out there this is
just a derivative as a rate of change of
this realized price metric and so you
can see despite since say august we've
had 90 billion around there of capital
inflows on a relative basis it hasn't
been that much given just the market
size of bitcoin it's obviously grown a
lot since 2017. um and so just on a
relative basis just to kind of reiterate
uh capital inflows are here and they're
large but it's not enough to send
bitcoin parabolic just yet
got it and so then when we go ahead and
we look at the three month futures
annualized rolling basis
when you start thinking about realized
price in relationship to futures or
other types of uh of more exotic um you
know ways you can get exposure is there
a connection between those two things or
do you look at these as uh kind of
separate and distinct uh types of data
points but it's important to look at
them in totality to actually understand
what's happening with bitcoin
yeah i think um it's you know you kind
of have to look at all of these things
to get a big picture of the market and
the reason i included this chart uh and
obviously
basically this rolling basis the spread
between that futures price uh and the
spot price of bitcoin in this case the
three month futures and then we
annualize that out so say when when
yields are 20 really that's that basis
spread is about five uh five percent uh
but we annualize that that figure out
and so obviously there's a really really
uh strong correlation here and basically
what it's showing is that
while you haven't seen this realized
price or this realized cap metric um
grow a lot expand a lot in relative
terms
this chart is basically telling us that
derivative speculation uh and mostly by
incumbents uh with you know whether you
want to call them whales or uh you know
whether it's crypto hedge funds uh
basically the speculative bid in
derivative markets has been basically
the the largest part of this price
action uh over the last say quarter or
two quarters um
those organic capital flows that we saw
at like late 2020 early 2021 again are
here but it's just not enough to send
bitcoin really parabolic and uh when we
broke that all-time high and went to 69
000 uh it was mostly just derivative
market speculation that's been the
driving force
got it now you've got this uh bitcoin
price weighted by hourly perps funding
rate which is an absolute mouthful to
say uh explain what this is and then why
do you think this is so important to pay
attention to
yeah so perps is short for perpetual
futures it's another futures market
instrument and basically this is um and
the the purpose is that the largest
derivative contracts in crypto and
bitcoin um and so what you can see here
is uh weighted by the funding rate it it
essentially just kind of shows when
bitcoin's a little overheated to the
upside or downside or it's more just
kind of flat uh it's basically a way to
kind of show or to quantify that
speculative bid that speculative premium
um so fun when funding is really high
what that means is that derivatives that
uh price that contract price is ahead of
spot market price so that's you know
when that funding rate is very elevated
it's saying that that's the driving
force in the bitcoin market and you know
over the summer we saw the opposite uh
where that funding rate was a lot was
below
the
it was a negative funding rate and so
derivatives were driving the price lower
than spot and so that's why we kind of
got a big short sweeps and so it
oscillates uh and definitely there's
kind of a huge sentiment factor here
but that's kind of a lot of the reason
why bitcoin is is so volatile and we see
these these moves is these derivative
markets and understanding the dynamics
behind them
got it and so if we go ahead and then we
look at the u.s government bond yields
which i know you love talking about some
macro data uh help us understand why the
uh the bond yields are acting the way
they are and what that has to do with
bitcoin
yeah so obviously we've seen uh a seven
percent cpi print uh highest in 40 years
uh it comes at a time when when bond
yields are near historic lows uh in 2020
we kind of got to that historic low
point uh yields almost went to zero uh
and the fed funds rate is at zero or
zero 20 you know 25 basis points
basically there um and recently kind of
the feds come out a little bit hawkish
uh in 2022 saying we're gonna the
market's basically pricing in four rate
hikes and you can see this with say like
the government bond futures market uh
but you can see these yields are really
starting uh to bend upwards and and for
those that aren't familiar with bond
contracts yields are inverse with price
so when yields go up the price of bonds
go down and when global debt markets are
a few hundred trillion dollars uh and
that risk-free yield is starting to go
upwards this means that government bonds
are being sold um so a lot of things uh
equities uh bitcoin um as these yields
go up what it's saying is that these
prices are going down uh and just with
how the credit system works uh and and
all the collateral values essentially uh
it means kind of more of a risk off is
coming as as the cpi print is coming
really hot
got it and so when you start to look at
uh the fed rate hikes obviously there's
people who think there's going to be
three four we've also seen i don't know
uh jp morgan's uh ceo jamie dimon talk
about seven six uh where's your thought
process in terms of like what's more
likely is it a lot or is it yeah maybe
we get like one to three
i think what the fed's trying to do now
is they're really trying to uh they're
really trying to get markets to correct
a little bit without doing too much
they're trying to talk markets down
because they know everything's in a big
bubble um i i don't think they've had
oblivious uh apparently that futures
market's pricing at about four rate
hikes uh in december of 2022 so it's
pricing in a fed funds rate of 125 basis
points 1.25 right now it's at 25 basis
points um and so that's the expectation
and i think they're going to hike until
something breaks i mean that's what
they've been doing for basically uh the
last decade or two
they try to tighten when when the
economy is running hot and then they end
up breaking something in the bond market
or the debt markets then
they reverse course and so i think
that's kind of my base case here i don't
know how far they get but credit markets
are already starting to uh to gurgle a
little bit you can kind of see that
contagion already starting to to unfold
and so uh i guess we'll see how far they
get
all right now we've got the s p 500
reported earnings yield compared to the
u.s treasury 10-year bond yield uh when
you look at this what is this showing
you
yeah so the s p 500 earnings yield this
is essentially this is the inverse of
the p e ratio p e ratio is just a way to
kind of value a stock price to earnings
how expensive relatively is a stock um
so when you see this this blue line
that's the s p earnings yields what it's
showing is that's p e ratios are
continuing to go up and it's very very
correlated this earnings yield with the
10-year treasury um and so
you know when we're in an environment
where real yields are are deeply
negative that's that cpi at seven and
the ten the ten-year treasury at say uh
1.1.5 or 1.6 uh what it's really showing
is that
that's the reason that equities are
going to the moon and so as as the
market starts to price in uh some rate
hikes some sustained inflation uh
whatever the case may be for these bonds
to start selling off uh what that's kind
of also a pretty you know a pretty heavy
force for these equity markets to sell
off uh the discount rate on on uh all of
these equities uh if yields go up um the
valuations of these companies get
crushed and so when you're starting to
see tax sell off if you look at say
arc innovation and their etf a lot of
these long-duration growth stock
companies that that aren't very
profitable and they're being priced out
at really high insanely high multiples
the reason those are selling off is
because of this
this
developing environment of potentially
higher yields and that's what the
market's pricing in
yeah it's uh it's fascinating to watch
this all kind of occur uh given uh
what's going on in the in the crypto
market and then we've got the uh bitcoin
s p 500 realized correlation which seems
to be like the topic du jour of uh tons
of both macro investors and also
mainstream media of just like is bitcoin
and the s p 500 correlated and how
should we think about that what's your
take uh on this chart
yeah so this is the the rolling
one-month correlation right now it's
about a 56
56
so it's you know pretty pretty well
correlated here and over longer time
frames i think that correlation breaks
down further but really uh when we're
this kind of late in a debt cycle
everything's uh riding the tide of of
expanding or contracting liquidity and
so uh when we're starting to see that
tide pull back a little bit uh bitcoin
is is
is treated by many as a risk asset but i
think what what is often still you know
the information asymmetry is still very
strong is that ultimately uh bitcoin is
also a risk-off asset in the sense that
yes during a liquidity crunch during a
during a period where the dollar gets
bid uh say march of 2020 bitcoin is
going to take a brief hit but ultimately
the store value uh
thesis for bitcoin isn't isn't wrong
there is a production cost there is a uh
way to custody your bitcoin with zero
counterparty risk uh unlike any other
asset before and so in that sense um
bitcoin is a risk-off asset and is
something that you want to own in a
deflationary environment if it is
allowed to play out and i think the
reality is is that deflationary
environment however long it takes to
unfold i think it's not going to be
allowed to persist for too long because
uh this this global everything bubble
just can't uh can't take it and so uh
while this correlation is is pretty
strong and if equity markets sell off as
as the market prices in a fed hike or
fed multiple fed hikes i think the
reality is um you know the macro funds
uh these investors that are looking just
at correlations and not a fundamental
understanding of bitcoin they're going
to sell the asset and that's okay
because the people that are you know
have conviction
and understand the thesis for a
non-sovereign uh asset in the digital
age that can't be printed or manipulated
they they understand what bitcoin is and
are happy to buy at a discount so really
there's a strong argument that there's
been a financialization of bitcoin
there's a different set of holders now
they're going to treat this like their
risk asset versus the you know kind of
quote-unquote bitcoiners who are going
to actually just hold bitcoin as their
reserve asset and so even though it's
the same asset when you have different
people holding it for different reasons
it gets treated differently and there's
almost a mismatch to some degree of how
much money the wall street and financial
institutions have versus the you know
average pleb who says no this is my
reserve currency is that a fair way to
think about it
it's a great way to think about it and i
think the financialization of bitcoin is
always going to happen as bitcoin is a
you know 800 billion dollar asset today
it's going to be a 5 trillion 10
trillion dollar asset at some point the
larger it gets i think the more pure uh
basically the more pure it becomes at
showing the the everything bubble and
just being a representation of the the
credit expansion and credit contractions
in the legacy system we've seen that in
2020 and 2021 uh and now going into 2022
and i think it's going to become
increasingly true into the future it's
just basically a a
calling the bluff of the central bank
put and it's basically a check on the
fed to say however you're responsible
you are however far you want to take
this
people have an opt-out and so whenever
they do reverse course on these hikes
and they will uh depending on when the
the system breaks when it when there's a
big crack in the bond market or in
equities if say equities drop 20
uh i think the the reaction of bitcoin
will be quite telling uh from that point
but we'll have to wait a little bit for
that in my opinion got it and when you
start to think about that
financialization uh obviously um if we
kind of think of on the far left maybe
the spectrum you have the individual the
retail investor they're treating bitcoin
as uh that reserve asset on the far
right extreme uh i think that it becomes
really interesting when you think about
maybe a nation state and like if you
look at el salvador like they're holding
it as a quote-unquote reserve asset as
well they're not trading it they're not
treating it like a macro risk asset but
in the middle is the wall street firms
the organizations and so is it
concerning to you or is it a positive
signal that retail and countries almost
act the same uh versus the institutions
uh on wall street like is it just time
horizon difference or like why is it
that an individual in this nation state
act the same but a a trading firm uh or
some sort of bank they have much more of
a short time horizon
yeah i think that's a fair way to put it
i think ultimately bitcoin is just in
this monetization phase and it's slowly
entrenching itself on everyone's balance
sheet uh in the entire world uh when you
decide to make it you know to allocate
to bitcoin you're saying i'm gonna hold
this on the right side of my balance
sheet on the asset side of my balance
sheet uh and there's assets and
liabilities everywhere
and so ultimately the dollar being that
world reserve currency uh there's a lot
of dollar denominated liabilities out
there and so uh depending on say
someone's risk management or their asset
and liability structure or breakdown uh
would say something like like a hedge
fund uh or a pension fund or an
endowment um where they're holding say
u.s treasury securities or anything else
uh bitcoin is going to be treated in
that risk bucket right it's a risk on
asset it is a high beta play on central
bank liquidity uh and for the for the
plebs or say for el salvador uh they're
saying we're gonna adopt it as legal
tender we're gonna adopt this as our
unit of account and we just wanna
accumulate uh and so i think ultimately
everybody is kind of
uh
depending on on how they play it but
it's still just monetizing it's a new
asset it's still only 13 years old and
people will allocate and play to to how
they want and i think ultimately it
transfers from that risk on asset to
just being a risk-off asset as people
kind of understand that the endgame of
central bank uh and fiat currencies is
always uh
basically
perpetual inflation perpetual monetary
expansion yeah it's crazy jojo what
questions you guys got what's up dylan
uh mine's just around news so
i think it was this morning cash app
announced that they're integrating the
lightning network where u.s customers
will be able to send bitcoin anywhere in
the world instantaneous for free
uh how does news like this play into
your mind when it comes to like the
broader price action that we might see
yeah it's i mean it's a huge
announcement and i think the market
doesn't really understand how big it is
uh just the the normalization of an
adoption of bitcoin and second layer
solutions like lightning how many square
terminals are there in the us or around
the world right like what what jack mars
is doing what jack dorsey is doing uh
it's it's really really exciting and all
this stuff like lightning network
integration it's a completely open open
network so anybody can can plug into
this thing just like twitter did right
they just connected their api and so
this is not something where price will
spike like say uh if there was some
small cap uh altcoin announced some some
some news the price would would spike 10
or 20 percent or if some you know
gamestop announced that they were
accepting bitcoin or dogecoin
the price pumps well with bitcoin at a
you know 800 billion dollar asset it's
it's not gonna it's not going to pump on
news like that it's ultimately just
about the supply and demand dynamics
that take sometimes weeks months
quarters years to unfold
that supply squeeze thesis isn't wrong
it's just often a little early and
derivatives kind of mask what's truly
happening
but when someone like square comes out
and says we're building on the lighting
network i think
the the logical thinkers the people that
have that have been around tech for a
while can kind of see what's what's
happening under the surface and just you
know how powerful these network effects
ultimately are uh and i think that's
that's something that's quite
misunderstood in my opinion it's not
priced in
john what you got for us
dylan so intel also came out this
morning and basically stated that that
they are going to create um mining rigs
for people at a lower low energy and
very efficient rigs how does that affect
the hash rate and like is there a cap on
how like many miners can be on the
network at once like is there
at some point does it become bad for the
network with too many monitors or not at
all
no i there is no cap and i think
ultimately there's there's the largest
economic incentive in the world to
continue to spin up and plug in these
miners uh if you have any sort of waste
energy underutilized energy resource uh
bitcoin is going to come in bitcoin
mining and they're gonna
basically they're going to harvest that
under utilized energy and almost flatten
out uh these these power costs around
the world we're just starting to see
that play out but it's a no-brainer for
all these um semiconductor manufacturers
uh chip manufacturers to get into
bitcoin uh mining production or just uh
whether that's asics or uh you started
to see like uh there's gpus for for
other crypto networks that are that are
being produced and there's a super high
demand for these chips because because
they're so valuable and and so it's a
no-brainer and i think it's it's
ultimately very encouraging uh we want
to see competition in this in this field
and for a while it was uh kind of
dominated by a monopoly with bitmain and
so just to see other other people uh
announce their uh i think square
announced that they were going to
produce uh bitcoin miners they were
going to attempt to block block stream
has also announced uh they acquired an
asic manufacturer and so to kind of see
this this competition and potentially to
see it on board and onshore in the
united states is very encouraging it's
good development yep
dylan we just uh got news that uh intel
a 220 billion dollar industry leader in
hardware manufacturing and
chip computation um
is
gonna launch a low voltage kind of uh
high impact um bitcoin asic for mining
when you see a player like that start to
participate in the industry
uh
is that just like a yeah of course like
everyone's gonna do this
or is that something else that like is
at play here like like intel right this
isn't bitmain this isn't some no-name
firm that's like oh [ __ ] we gotta throw
the hail mary pass intel does whatever
the hell intel wants to do
and they're gonna get into bitcoin
mining like what do you what's your take
on that
have you seen the price of asics
recently i mean it's a no-brainer
um yeah i mean they're all going to come
uh i mean a safe manufacturing as a
percent of total semiconductor
production is still very small i think
it's less than one percent um and so
that's gonna that that number is gonna
grow uh and demand for asics is gonna
continue to skyrocket uh bitcoin mining
margins are still
pretty ridiculous and i think the end
game is that there is a going to be a
commod like a commoditization of asic
miners
and profit margins uh for for bitcoin
matters over the long term not next year
maybe not the year after but 10 years
out 50 years out 100 years out profit
margins are going to be very very thin
as it's the most competitive
industry in the world or it's going to
be anybody can plug in this these asics
and ultimately the the ones that will
win or probably have that power cost
near zero uh and so in the meantime uh
there's still this this huge uh
incentive to plug these things in and
profit margins are not near zero uh you
can almost you can plug in at 20 cents
per
terawatt or per kilowatt hour and still
be profitable in a lot of places that's
like that's like plugging it in out of
your outlet at home uh and so
in in the meantime i think asics are
going to continue to be manufactured at
a pretty rapid pace and hatch rate's
going to go exponential i've seen some
estimates that hash rate's going to
increase by 50 here in 2022 so
a lot of these things are going to be
plugged in and i think that the price of
basics is going to continue to go up by
a lot
when you think about hash rate and price
and the relationship there does hash
rate pull price or does price pull hash
rate
what came first the chicken or the egg
depends who yes
yeah i mean that's a i think you know
rising hatch rate strengthens network
security uh it reinforces the
immutability of bitcoin uh and it you
know expands network effects and thus uh
bitcoin becomes more valuable so more
people allocate to it uh it's it's a
really tough question i i think there's
no definitive answer there but uh i'm
bullish on rising hatch rate and bullish
on on rising network security
got it
you guys got any other questions no
thanks for coming on i got well hold on
i got one more
just question nice to our guests here
all right
calm it down all right
dylan
as you look forward over the next 12
months we're still in january so let's
say 12 months by the end of this year
what is the one thing that you think has
a high probability of happening that
most people are completely ignoring or
aren't talking enough about is there one
thing we were like bam this is gonna
happen in my opinion but a lot of people
aren't we recently saw fidelity talk
about other countries adopting bitcoin
and things like that like is there one
thing that you're saying completely
undervalued by the market or not being
spoken about enough
yeah i mean that fidelity thing was
pretty big i mean a lot of bitcoiners
have been talking about it uh but it's
been more of a kind of a niche thing and
to see some giant like fidelity come out
and reinforce that that opinion and that
sentiment is is obviously very strong i
think the 2020 midterms are going to be
really really interesting um i know
behind the scenes there's a lot of
people uh working on bitcoin advocacy uh
and and basically uh championing uh pro
bitcoin candidates and i think what
we'll see is any uh crypto bitcoin
opposition uh from political from
political candidates uh they'll get
ousted and those pro bitcoin candidates
uh are gonna are gonna be elected uh i
think i think in big numbers um and i
think we're just starting to see a lot
of those politicians come out and so
the the narrative that the u.s or that
bitcoin is is pro-capitalism pro-freedom
uh and as a u.s kind of
uh as a us asset and
cbdc's are more of a of a communist
chinese uh eastern
eastern sort of asset or sort of uh
idealism is something that i don't think
is priced in uh and the market's still
kind of there's still people that will
say bitcoin is going to be banned and i
and it kind of blows my mind i
understand not everyone's
living and breathing in the industry
every single day but i don't think
that's priced in the u.s just
basically bitcoin becoming uh the sort
of thing that if you are opposed to it
in the political spectrum or the
political sphere you stand no chance um
and so that i think is a development
that we'll we'll start to see in in big
numbers in 2022 and by 2024 i think
it'll be uh pretty pretty understood
that if you are are not pro bitcoin uh
then then you don't stand a chance in us
politics
yeah
i definitely agree with that i'm not
gonna say much more but um
the elaboration that i'll provide is
that there are a lot of candidates right
now who have recognized this and it's
similar to challengers in the technology
industry going up against incumbents
they constantly look for an edge and so
what do they do they try to build
disruptive technology to get network
effects to get some sort of advantage on
customer acquisition distribution etc
and the incumbents usually try to use
regulatory capture uh their size their
balance sheet right all the things and
and pretty much people know in
technology what are the advantages of a
challenger you know speed innovation
strategy versus the advantages of an
incumbent
uh
it's playing on politics right now
there's a lot of incumbent politicians
who think this is the dumbest stuff in
the world they want nothing to do with
it they think that everyone who touches
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies or digital
uh technologies like this they're
criminals they're bad people they're
cheering for the demise of the united
states etc
and there's a whole bunch of challengers
who recognize the exact opposite and
realize that this is a generational
shift in the way people think and the
way that they actually hold their wealth
and the way that they actually interface
and communicate with each other etc
and
it's fascinating to me to watch people
who are not even in elected office yet
already reaching out and trying to
establish support with the bitcoin
crypto industry and to
allow people to know
if you're a one issue voter
i'm on the right side of your issue you
know basically vote for me because i
believe what you believe and there's not
very many issues in american politics
where people are one issue voters right
there's you know maybe some gun stuff
there uh probably some healthcare stuff
but you know there's a couple there's
not many
and now somehow bitcoin uh and the
crypto industry in uh a larger uh sense
has become a one issue for literally
hundreds of thousands millions of people
and so there's entire you know kind of
political monopolies on a single seat
that have happened because somebody was
in a certain jurisdiction with a certain
view of the world and they said i stand
for this and i'm gonna always be this
and if you're this one issue voter vote
for me
and the best examples are like you know
guns in texas right is the the kind of
meme but there's a truth in the meme
i think throughout the country they're
gonna be people who establish
political monopolies on certain seats
by just saying i'm pro this technology i
want to see everyone be successful
that's in this industry and the wealth
creation the tailwind the flow of
intellectual capital et cetera into the
industry will carry that person for
literally decades to come in the
political realm uh all the way to the
point where eventually one of those
people can become a president of the
united states it just may take you know
10 15 20 years but it's gonna happen at
some point and i don't think that that's
being priced in by you know uh many
people in the political arena
no it's not at all um brad sherman's
cooked uh he's done um
yeah i mean it's really encouraging to
see that not many people understand
what's unfolding um and so i mean i'm
getting a little bit of a behind the
scenes look uh and it's it's definitely
really exciting i mean i'm a single
issue voter i didn't vote in 2020. i
think for the most part bipartisan
politics doesn't get you anywhere um so
you know champion bitcoin stand up for
pro freedom and you'll get my vote
seems like a pretty uh pretty good pitch
to a politician i like that
is your view of the world dylan that uh
politicians are gonna have to capitulate
to the bitcoiners
yeah i think so uh and there's it's kind
of a paradox because ultimately
embracing bitcoin like for say uh
buchelle right uh embracing bitcoin uh
this thing that he has no control over
um and he didn't have his own currency
to begin with but it ultimately reduces
the power of the state uh marginally i
think actually uh quite a quite a bit
but uh there is a paradox there that
embracing bitcoin ultimately uh will
kind of strip a lot of the
the the fiat decree that politicians
have currently um and obviously that's
that's not too well understood but the
incentives are are aligned where they
they should because there's a whole lot
of capital and a whole lot of people in
the world across demographics across
races across sexes across uh both
parties uh that is that are these
single-issue voters and so uh that's
something that i think this last five
minutes that what we've been talking
about it's not remotely priced in uh or
understood for that matter
i think that you are very right my
friend all right how we looking on uh on
subs for uh for twitter and for the
newsletter let's anyone who uh who does
not follow dylan yet on twitter you're
wrong let's go make sure 106 000. let's
go there we go i'm gonna get i think
300k by the end of the year easy book it
yeah he's like yeah that's going to
happen
300 that's it
i mean i think it's not about me
i'm talking about dylan's potential here
how many did you have uh you know 353
but who's counting 300
353 can you get to a million this year
oh he said you got more faith than me
huh over here dylan is 3x
okay and what's dealing at 100 can you
get to 300 all right are you gonna get
to uh three million yeah no that's not
three x
that's less than three that is less than
three x all right there's ah come on we
told you 353 what up dylan dylan i just
want to call out here very quickly wait
go back pull that back up real quick i
just want to call out in his bio
third word now look at the third word
sports business and bitcoin and the
tailwinds here
that's like that's the male equivalent
of a finance thirst trap right there
going on in the twitter account like we
won't even start with yours all right
see ya
thank you for joining us man we
appreciate it anyone who uh who wants uh
for i forgot to mention this last week
uh so we'll post some clips from this
conversation uh today maybe tomorrow and
then uh we'll post a full interview
sunday uh the video will come out and uh
you can listen to the podcast episode
tomorrow so i had people uh uh i don't
want to say who it is dylan but i'll
text it to you who who messaged me
there's somebody who runs a very very
large tens of billions of dollar asset
management firm who dm'd me on twitter
last week and said where are the charts
i'm listening to this guy talk about
charts there's no charts because listen
to the podcast episode so i had to go
send them to him and he watched he goes
okay very smart very smart i i enjoyed
that conversation so you uh you got the
eyes and ears of uh
of uh of the right people so keep it up
love to hear it appreciate you giving me
the platform all right buddy we'll talk
soon
peace